This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vietanthu. On a September evening in 2016, Terence Croucher's SUV stopped in the middle of a road in Tulsa, Oklahoma. A woman saw him step out of the car. The doors of the car were open. The engine was still running. The woman called 911. Officer Betty Shelby was on her way to an unrelated incident when the call came in.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹坦。2016年9月的一个傍晚，特伦斯·克劳彻的SUV停在俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨市的一条马路中间。一名女子看到他从车里走出来。车门开着，发动机还在运转。这名女子拨打了911。接到报警时，警员贝蒂·谢尔比正赶往一起不相关的事件现场。
Terence was 40, African American, born and raised in Tulsa. He was a churchgoing man with four children. Betty was 42, white, her mother. She was born in a small town not far from Tulsa. In an ideal world, these two Oklahoma natives, close an age, ought to have had more to bring them together than to hold them apart. But on this evening, there was no small talk or friendly chatter. The police officer told Terrence to take his hands out of his pockets.
特伦斯40岁，是一名非裔美国人，在塔尔萨出生长大。他是一个经常去教堂的人，育有四个孩子。贝蒂42岁，白人，是一位母亲。她出生在离塔尔萨不远的一个小镇上。在一个理想的世界里，这两个年龄相仿、土生土长的俄克拉荷马州人，本应该有更多让他们走到一起的东西，而不是让他们产生隔阂。但在这个傍晚，没有闲聊，也没有友好的交谈。这名警官命令特伦斯把手从口袋里拿出来。
According to her attorney, he first complied. He then put his hands up in the air. Moments later, he put his hands back in his pockets. By this point multiple police officers had gathered and drawn their guns and tasers. Overhead, a police chopper filmed events as they unfolded. From the video, it's hard to tell exactly what's happening on the ground, but an officer in the helicopter thinks Terence isn't cooperating. I'm for Terence, I think. That looks like a bad dude too, to be honest.
据她的律师称，他起先照做了。然后他把双手举在空中。片刻之后，他又把手放回了口袋里。此时，多名警察已经聚集起来，拔出了枪和泰瑟枪。头顶上，一架警用直升机拍摄了事态的发展过程。从视频中很难看出地面上究竟发生了什么，但直升机上的一名警员认为特伦斯很不配合。我想我是支持特伦斯的，我觉得。说实话，那家伙看起来也像个坏蛋。
Moments later, one officer on the ground does fire a teaser. Betty shall be, fires her gun. God fired! Oh, 3, 3, 1, we have a gun fire, we have one shot right now. We need to enter here. She kills Terence Croucher. Later, police discover that he was unarmed. Soon accusations are flying. Maybe the victim was high on drugs. Others said maybe the police officer was racist. At a press conference after the shooting,
片刻之后，地面上的一名警察确实发射了泰瑟枪。贝蒂·谢尔比开枪了。开枪了！哦，3，3，1，我们有枪声，我们现在开了一枪。我们需要进到这里。她杀死了特伦斯·克劳彻。随后，警方发现他当时并没有携带武器。很快，指责声四起。也许受害者当时吸了毒。其他人则说，也许这名女警察是个种族主义者。在枪击事件发生后的新闻发布会上，
a journalist asked Scott Wood, Betty Shelby's attorney, about that theory. Did him being a big black man play a role in her perceived danger? No, him being a large man perceived a role in her being in danger. She's worked in this part of town for quite some time. And, you know, just the week before, she was at an all black high school, homecoming football game. She's not afraid of black people.
一名记者问贝蒂·谢尔比的律师斯科特·伍德关于这种说法的看法。他是一个身材高大的黑人男性，这是否在他被认为具有危险性中起到了作用？没有，他是一个身材高大的男性，这在人们认为他具有危险性中起到了一部分作用。她在这片辖区工作了相当长的一段时间。而且，就在前一周，她还去过一所全黑人高中的返校节美式橄榄球赛。她并不害怕黑人。
Terence Croucher's sister Tiffany sees it very differently. She thinks her brother was shot because he was black. That big bad dude was my twin brother. That big bad dude was my twin brother. That big bad dude was a father. That big bad dude was a son. That big bad dude was enrolled at Tulsa Community College. Just wanting to make us proud. Betty Shelby's daughter, Amber, defended her mother. I am here to reveal to you the
特伦斯·克劳彻的妹妹蒂凡尼对此有截然不同的看法。她认为她的兄弟被枪杀是因为他是黑人。那个身材高大、十恶不赦的家伙是我的双胞胎哥哥。那个身材高大、十恶不赦的家伙是我的双胞胎哥哥。那个身材高大、十恶不赦的家伙是一位父亲。那个身材高大、十恶不赦的家伙是一个儿子。那个身材高大、十恶不赦的家伙曾在塔尔萨社区学院注册就读。他只是想让我们为他感到骄傲。贝蒂·谢尔比的女儿琥珀为她的母亲进行了辩护。我来这里是为了向你们展示我母亲
side of my mother that the public does not know. My mother is an incredible supportive, loving and caring woman. She is a wife, a mother, and a grandmother with a heart of gold. She has always fought for the underdog and stands up for the weak. And so it went with accusations against and defenses for the person who pulled the trigger and the person who got shot. Betty Shelby was acquitted of manslaughter charges. Still, the tenor of the back and forth, the psychological accusations and psychological defenses, is very revealing. When an incident like this occurs, we want to hear the story of what happened.
不为人知的一面。我的母亲是一个极其支持他人、充满爱心和关怀的女性。她是一位妻子、母亲和一个有着金子般心的祖母。她一直在为处于弱势的人战斗，并为弱者挺身而出。针对扣动扳机的人和被枪击的人的指责与辩护就这样展开了。贝蒂·谢尔比被判过失杀人罪名不成立。尽管如此，这种来回指责的基调、心理上的指控以及心理上的辩护，还是极具启示意义的。当这样一起事件发生时，我们想要听到关于发生了什么的故事。
We want to know what was going on in the mind of the shooter and the mind of the victim. Was Terence Cratcher truly a threat? Did Betty Shelby dislike black people? What clues explain the behavior of these individuals? We home in, dig for facts, and look for psychological explanations. But what if there's another way to think about what happened, one that has less to do with the individuals involved, and more to do with the
我们想知道开枪者和受害者的内心在想什么。特伦斯·克劳彻真的构成威胁吗？贝蒂·谢尔比讨厌黑人吗？有什么线索可以解释这些人的行为？我们深入追查，挖掘事实，寻找心理学上的解释。但是，如果我们换一种方式来思考发生的这一切呢？这种方式与涉事个人的关系较小，而与枪击事件发生的背景关系更大？
context in which the shooting occurred? What we're discovering here is that the individual mind sits in society and the connection between mind and society is an extremely important one that should not be forgotten. Individual behavior and the mind of the village today on Hidden Brain. I'm Maserine Banaji. Maserine is a psychology professor at Harvard. She's made a career out of studying the invisible. For the past 30 years, I've been interested in studying those aspects of our minds that are hidden
我们在这里发现的是，个人意识植根于社会之中，意识与社会之间的联系极其重要，绝不能被忽视。今天的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨个人行为与群体意识。我是马扎林·巴纳吉。马扎林是哈佛大学的一位心理学教授。她一生都在研究看不见的东西。在过去的30年中，我一直致力于研究那些隐藏在我们有意识的觉察之外的思维方面。
from our own conscious awareness. Ma Zareen's interest began in graduate school. She was teaching psychology at Yale and looking for a way to measure people's biases. There was debate over the right scientific method to do this. You could simply ask people their views, but because prejudice is a sensitive topic, you often don't get anything. You couldn't walk up to somebody and say, do you agree that Italians are lazy and have them say yes or no? They'll just refuse to answer that question.
马扎林的兴趣始于研究生院。当时她在耶鲁大学教心理学，并寻找一种测量人们偏见的方法。关于这样做的正确科学方法曾存在争议。你可以直接询问人们的观点，但由于偏见是一个敏感话题，你往往得不到任何结果。你不能走到某个人面前说：“你同意意大利人很懒吗？”然后让他们回答“是”或“不是”。他们只会拒绝回答这个问题。
A deep-seated discomfort about discussing prejudice was one hurdle for a researcher looking to study the phenomenon. Marzine realized there was another barrier. What if some forms of prejudice are so deeply buried that people themselves don't realize they harbor such bias? Perhaps we behave in ways that are not known to our own conscious awareness, that we are being driven to act in certain ways not because we're explicitly prejudiced, but because we may carry in our heads the thumbprint of the culture.
对于想要研究这种现象的研究人员来说，对讨论偏见根深蒂固的不适感是一个障碍。马扎林意识到还有另一个障碍。如果某些形式的偏见埋藏得如此之深，以至于人们自己都没有意识到他们心存这种偏见，那该怎么办？也许我们的行为方式是我们自己有意识的觉察所不知道的，我们之所以被驱动着以某种特定方式行事，不是因为我们有显性的偏见，而是因为我们的脑海中可能带有文化的指纹。
Was there a way to decipher this thumbprint and expose people's hidden biases? Eventually, Ma Zareen, with the help of her mentor, Tony Greenwald, and then graduate student Brian Nosek, developed a simple, ingenious test. It's called the Implicit Association Test test or the IAT. It's based on the way we group things in our minds. When you say bread, my mind will easily think butter, but not something unrelated to it. Like say a hammer. Our brains make associations, and these associations can reveal something
有没有办法解读这个指纹并揭露人们隐藏的偏见呢？最终，马扎林在她的导师托尼·格林沃尔德以及当时的研究生布莱恩·诺塞克的帮助下，开发了一个简单而巧妙的测试。它被称为隐式联想测验，简称IAT。它基于我们在脑海中对事物进行分组的方式。当你 说“面包”时，我的大脑会很容易联想到“黄油”，而不是与之无关的东西。比如一把锤子。我们的大脑会产生联想，而这些联想可以揭示出关于我们思考方式的重要信息。
important about the way we think. So the way the IAT works is to simply ask people to sort things. So imagine that you're given a deck of playing cards, and you're asked to sort all the red cards to the left, and all the black cards to the right. I'll predict that it will take you about 20 seconds to run through that deck. Next, Mazarin says, shuffle the deck and resort the cards. This time, I'd like you to put all the spades and the diamonds to one side and the clubs and the hearts to the other side. And what we'll find is that this will take you nearly twice as long to do.
因此，IAT的工作原理就是简单地要求人们对事物进行分类。所以想象一下，给你一副扑克牌，要求你把所有的红牌分到左边，所有的黑牌分到右边。我预测你大约需要20秒就能过完这副牌。接下来，马扎林说，洗牌并重新给这些牌分类。这一次，我希望你把所有的黑桃和方块放在一边，把梅花和红桃放在另一边。我们会发现，你做这件事需要花费将近两倍的时间。
Why? Because a rule that your brain had learned, red and red go together, black and black go together is no longer available to you. Remember that in both scenarios, you are grouping two suits together. In the first scenario, you're grouping hearts with diamonds and clubs with spades. In the second scenario, you're grouping hearts with clubs and diamonds with spades. Because the second scenario, you're grouping hearts with clubs and diamonds with spades. Because there's a simple rule for the first task, group red with red and black with black, that task is easy. In the second scenario, you need a fraction of a second
为什么？因为你大脑已经学会的一个规则——红色和红色归为一类，黑色和黑色归为一类——不再适用了。请记住，在这两种情况下，你都是将两种花色归为一组。在第一种情况下，你将红桃与方块归为一组，梅花与黑桃归为一组。在第二种情况下，你将红桃与梅花归为一组，方块与黑桃归为一组。因为第一个任务有一个简单的规则，即红色与红色归类，黑色与黑色归类，所以那个任务很简单。在第二种情况下，你需要花一小部分时间来思考每一张牌。你无法遵循一个简单的经验法则。
to think about each card. You can't follow a simple rule of thumb. Maserine and Tony and Brian had an important insight. These rules of association apply to many subjects, including the way we think about other human beings. So they created a new sorting task. Sort, for me, faces of black people and bad things together, words like devil and bomb and vomit and awful and failure. Sort
马扎林、托尼和布莱恩有一个重要的见解。这些联想规则适用于许多主题，包括我们看待其他人类的方式。因此，他们创造了一个新的分类任务。为我把黑人的面孔和不好的事物归为一组，比如魔鬼、炸弹、呕吐物、糟糕和失败这些词。把这些放在扑克牌的一边。在另一边，放上白人的面孔。以及像爱与和平、享受和阳光、友善等等的词语放在另一边。事实证明，这对我们来说很容易做到，正如我和我的同事们将要论证的那样，白人与好、黑人与坏的联想已经在我们的文化中为我们建立好了。测试并没有就此结束。
those on one side of the playing deck. On the other side, put the faces of white people. And words like love and peace, enjoy and sunshine and friendly and so on to the other side. This turns out to be pretty easy for us to do because as my colleagues and I will argue, the association of white and good and black and bad has been made for us in our culture. The test doesn't end there. After sorting white and good into one group and black and bad into another, you now have to do it again, this time grouping black with good and white with bad. And when you try to do that and when I try to do that,
在将白色与好归为一组、黑色与坏归为另一组之后，你现在必须再做一次，这一次将黑色与好归为一组，白色与坏归为一组。当你试图这样做以及当我试图这样做时，数据表明我们会慢下来，我们无法做得那么快，因为黑色与好对我们来说不是习惯性的反应。它们对我们来说不是习得的反应。我们必须施加控制才能让它发生，因为它对我们来说并不是自然而然、轻而易举的。这就是IAT。
the data show that we will slow down, that we can't do it quite as fast because black and good are not practice responses for us. They're not habitual responses for us. We have to exert control to make that happen because it doesn't come naturally and easily to us. That's the IAT.
顺便说一句，如果你想知道测试的顺序是否有影响，答案是没有。研究人员以不同的方式向志愿者提供了测试。先要求人们把黑色与坏归为一组，还是把黑色与好归为一组，并没有什么区别。在这两种情况下，人们都能更快地将白人的面孔与积极的词汇联系起来，将黑人的面孔与消极的词汇联系起来。马扎林认为，IAT测量的是一种隐式的或无意识的偏见形式。
By the way, if you're wondering whether the order of the test makes a difference, it doesn't. The researchers have presented tests to volunteers in different ways. It doesn't make a difference if you ask people to first group black with bad or to group black with good. In both cases, people are faster to associate white faces with positive words and black faces with negative words. Maserine thinks the IAT is measuring a form of bias that is implicit or unconscious.
马扎林本人也多次参加过IAT测试。令她沮丧的是，测试显示她有着很高程度的无意识偏见。我的大脑就是无法像将白色与好联系起来那样快地将黑色与好联系起来。这告诉我一些事情，它告诉我，不是IAT搞砸了，而是我的脑袋搞砸了。由于IAT是一项计时测试，因此结果可以精确测量。换句话说，隐式偏见是可以被量化的。大多数心理学测试只能在实验室里进行，但马扎林和她的同事们决定做一件激进的事情。
Maserine herself has taken the IAT many times. To her dismay, the tests show that she has robust levels of unconscious bias. My brain simply could not make the association of black with good as quickly as I could make the association of white with good. And that told me something, it told me, it's not the IAT that screwed up, it's my head that screwed up. Because the IAT is a timed test, the results can be precisely measured. Implicit bias in other words can be quantified. Most psychological tests are only available in the lab, but Maserine and her colleagues decided to do something radical.
他们把测试放到了互联网上。你今天可以在 implicit.harvard.edu 上找到它。数百万人参加了这项测试，数据被收集、分享和传播。如今，IAT被广泛认为是研究无意识偏见最具影响力的测试。正当马扎林、托尼和布莱恩在开发IAT时，其他研究人员也在开发测量偏见的不同方法。心理学家约书亚·科雷尔发现自己涉足这一领域是在1999年纽约市一名黑人男子被枪杀后不久。他的名字叫阿马杜·迪亚洛。迪亚洛。迪亚洛当时赤手空拳地站在他公寓楼的前门阶上，警察认为他看起来很可疑，于是靠近他，最终开枪打死了他。
They put their test on the internet. You can find it today at implicit.harvard.edu. Millions of people have taken this test, the data has been collected, shared, disseminated. The IAT is widely considered today to be the most influential test of unconscious bias. As Maasurine and Tony and Brian were developing the IAT, other researchers were developing different ways to measure bias. Psychologist Joshua Correll found himself diving into the field shortly after a black man was shot and killed in New York City in 1999. His name, Amidou Diallo. Dealo. Dealo was standing unarmed on the front stoop of his apartment building and the police thought he looked suspicious and they approached him and they
每个人都在问的问题是——这也是全国各地的人们都在琢磨的事情——他被枪杀是因为他是黑人吗？当时，约书亚正开始读研究生。我非常认真地对待这个问题，我们试图找出如何在实验室里对其进行测试。约书亚和他的同事最终开发了一个电子游戏。这是一个相当糟糕的电子游戏，但它确实起到了作用。它更像是一个幻灯片放映，屏幕上会弹出一系列背景，然后其中一个关键背景中会突然出现一个人。
ended up shooting him and the question that everybody was asking and this was I mean something that people you know across the country were wondering about was was he shot because he was black. At the time, Joshua was starting graduate school. I took that question pretty seriously and we tried to figure out how we could test it in a laboratory. Joshua and his colleagues eventually developed a video game. It was a pretty bad video game, but it did the trick. It's more like a slideshow where there are a series of backgrounds that pop up on the
它更像是一个幻灯片放映，屏幕上会弹出一系列背景，然后其中一个关键背景中会突然出现一个人。所以我们有大约25个白人男性和25个黑人男性的照片，我们拍摄了这些人拿着各种不同物品的照片。手机、一罐可乐、钱包、一把银色手枪、一把黑色手枪。我们只是编辑了这些照片，让一个人拿着一个物件出现在背景中，然后玩家必须决定如何反应。他们的指令是：如果屏幕上的家伙有枪，他就是个坏人，你应该向他开枪。你得尽可能快地做到这一点。
screen, and then in one of those critical backgrounds, a person will suddenly appear. It's more like a slideshow where there are a series of backgrounds that pop up on the screen and then in one of those critical backgrounds a person will suddenly appear. So we've got photographs of say 25 or so white men and 25 black men and we've photographed these guys holding a variety of different objects. Cell phones, can a coke, a wallet, a silver pistol, a black pistol. And so we've just edited the photographs so that the person pops up in the background holding an object and the player has to decide how to respond. And they're instructed, if the guy on the screen has a gun, he's a bad guy and you're supposed
约书亚想知道的是，玩家是否会根据屏幕上目标种族的不同而做出不同的反应。比如一个黑人跳出来拿着钱包，一个白人跳出来拿着钱包，黑人被枪杀而白人没有被枪杀的可能性有多大？如果时事能提供任何线索，你大概能猜到答案。这里我们看到的是，比如说，玩家对一个拿着钱包的目标做出反应，正确的决定是不开枪。我们发现的是，如果目标是白人而不是黑人，他们会更快地做出“不开枪”的决定。
to shoot him. And you're supposed to do that as quickly as you possibly can. What Joshua wanted to know was whether players would respond differently depending on the race of the target on the screen. Say a black eye pops up holding a wallet and a white guy pops up holding a wallet, what's the likelihood that the black eye gets shot and the white guy doesn't? If current events are any clue, you may guess the answer. Here we're looking at, say, you know, the player is responding to a target who's holding a wallet
持枪目标也是如此。测试对象对黑色目标的射击速度更快，对白色目标的射击速度更慢。现在，你可能会认为约书亚会得出结论，认为他的测试对象只是种族主义者。但约书亚的测试和马扎林的测试有一个重要的相似之处，那就是它们并不假定具有此类偏见的人对非裔美国人抱有积极的敌意。这些人不是三K党成员。这完全正如我们所预测的那样，我想两者既有期待也有担忧，对吧？
and the correct decision is to say don't shoot. And what we found is that they are faster to say don't shoot if the target is white rather than black. The same hell true for arm targets. Test takers were faster to shoot black targets, slower to shoot white ones. Now, you might think that Joshua would conclude that his test takers were just racist. But one important similarity between Joshua's test and Mazurine's test is that they do not presume that the people with such biases have active animosity to what African Americans. These are not members of the Ku Klux Klan. It was just exactly what we had predicted, and I guess both kind of hoped and feared, right?
我的意思是，这是一个激动人心的科学时刻，但它也暗示了一些深刻令人不安的事情：这些参与者本该是很好的人，没有私怨，他们不是极端分子，对黑人没有任何愤怒，但我们在他们的数据中非常非常清楚地看到了一种将黑人与威胁联系起来并更快向他们开枪的倾向。你可以看到，这两个心理学测试都是学术练习。
I mean, it's an exciting scientific moment, but it also suggests something kind of deeply troubling that these participants who are presumably nice people with no bone to pick, they're not bigots, they're not angry at black people in any way, but what we saw in their data very, very clearly is an tendency to associate black people with threat and to shoot them more quickly. You can see that both the psychological tests are academic exercises.
它们能说明人们在现实生活中的行为吗？约书亚·科雷尔非常明确地表示，他的电子游戏实验无法复制现实生活。他说，在实验室里重现现实世界中警察对峙可能产生的恐惧和压力是不可能的。IAT也因测试结果与现实世界行为之间有些模糊的联系而受到批评。人们已经进行了数百项研究，以探讨IAT是否能解释或预测人们的行为。结果毁誉参半。
Do they say anything about how people behave in real life? Joshua Corral is very clear that his video game experiment cannot replicate real life. It's impossible, he says, to recreate in a lab the fear and stress that a real-world police confrontation can generate. The IAT has also been criticized for a somewhat hazy link between test results and real-world behavior. Hundreds of studies have been conducted looking at whether the IAT explains or predicts how people will act. The results have been mixed.
在某些研究中，测试中的无意识种族偏见似乎可以预测人们的行为。例如，研究人员发现，在隐性偏见测试中得分高的医生，与白人患者相比，更不容易给黑人患者开溶栓心脏药。但其他同样以医生以及黑人和白人患者为对象的研究发现，偏见测试的结果与实际行为之间没有相关性。这种差异困扰着宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克。他是IAT的批评者。这是一个在直觉上极具吸引力的测试。
In some studies, unconscious racial bias on the test seems to predict how people will behave. Researchers found, for example, that doctors who score high and implicit bias are less likely to prescribe clot-busting hard drugs to black patients compared to white patients. But other studies, also looking at doctors and black and white patients, find no correlation between results on the bias test and actual behavior. This discrepancy bothers psychologists Phil Tetlock at the University of Pennsylvania. He is a critic of the IAT. It's a test that is enormously intuitively appealing.
我从未见过哪项心理学测试能像IAT那样迅速腾飞，并以这种方式抓住大众的想象力，因为它表面上看起来似乎在衡量某种类似偏见的东西。泰特洛克和其他批评者担心，仅仅因为某人在IAT上表现出偏见，并不意味着他们在现实生活中会以有偏见的方式行事。如果一项测试无法预测你实际会怎么做，那它不就只是一项学术练习吗？
I've never seen a psychological test take off the way the IAT has and is gripped the popular imagination the way it has, because it just seems on its surface to be measuring something like prejudice. Tetlock and other critics are concerned that just because someone shows bias on the IET doesn't mean that they're going to act in biased ways in real life. If a test cannot predict how you're actually going to behave, isn't it just an academic exercise? There is the question of whether or not people who score as prejudice on the IET actually
问题在于，在IAT测试中被评为有偏见的人，在现实情境中是否真的会对他人采取歧视性行为。如果他们没有这样做，如果这两者之间的关系接近于零，那么IAT到底在测量什么？事实证明，测量到了很多东西。有新的证据表明，IAT实际上确实可以预测行为，但要看到这一点，你必须把视野拉远。你必须放宽镜头，超越个人，审视整个社区。你好，我叫埃里克·海曼。他是瑞尔森大学的心理学教授。埃里克在研究警务中致命武力的使用时，对IAT产生了兴趣。
act in the discriminatory ways toward other human beings in real world situations. And if they don't, if there is very close to zero relationship between those two things, what exactly is the IET measuring? It turns out a lot. There's new evidence that suggests that the IET does in fact predict behavior, but to see it, you have to zoom out. You have to widen the lens to look beyond the individual and into the community. Hello, my name is Eric Haman. He's a psychology professor at Ryerson University. Eric became interested in the I.T. as he was researching the use of lethal force in policing.
他试图设计一个统计模型，以预测美国哪些地方的有色人种更有可能被警察 disproportionately（不成比例地）开枪打死。首先，他需要一些基线数据。事实证明这很难，因为联邦政府并不要求警察局报告警员的致命枪击事件。对于一些非常基本的问题，比如这些事件发生的频率、发生的地点以及受害者是谁，我们真的毫无所知。但在2015年，包括《华盛顿邮报》和英国《卫报》在内的一些新闻媒体开始汇编他们自己的美国警察凶杀案数据库。
He was trying to design a statistical model that would predict where in the United States people of color are disproportionately likely to be shot and killed by police. First, he needed some baseline data. This proved hard since the federal government does not require police departments to report deadly shootings by officers. We really had no idea about really basic questions such as how often they were happening, where they're happening, and who they were happening to. But in 2015 some news outlets, including the Washington Post and the British newspaper at the Guardian, began to compile their own database on police homicides in the United States.
根据官方术语，这些被称为正当杀人。因此，他们汇编的是美国这些正当杀人事件中最全面的清单。埃里克利用这些数据来查明少数族裔更有可能遭到警察不成比例枪击的地点。然后他转向了IAT数据。埃里克怀疑，如果偏见是警察枪击事件的一个因素，那么起作用的很可能是隐式偏见，而不是公开的种族主义。传统上，该领域发现显性偏见可以预测受我们有意识控制的行为，而隐式偏见则可以预测那些稍微更自动化、更难控制的行为。而这恰恰是我们认为可能涉及警察枪击的那种行为。
According to official terminology, these are known as justifiable homicides. So what they were putting together was the most comprehensive list of these justifiable homicides in the United States. Eric used this data to pinpoint where disproportionate police shootings of minorities were most likely. Then he turned to the IAT data. Eric suspected that if bias was a factor in police shootings, it was likely that implicit bias rather than overt racism was a play. Traditionally, the field has found that explicit biases predict behaviors that are under our conscious control, whereas implicit biases predict things that are a little bit more automatic, a little bit more difficult to control. And this is exactly this sort of behavior that we thought might be involved in police shootings.
人们匿名参加IAT，但他们需要提供一些信息，比如他们的种族和居住地。凭借IAT提供的数百万个数据点，埃里克绘制了一幅美国偏见地图。有些地方似乎有很多偏见，有些地方则很少。现在他有两个数据库。他将它们进行交叉比对，以查看少数族裔警察枪击比例过高的社区与表现出高水平隐式偏见的社区之间是否存在任何联系。
People take the IAT anonymously, but they need to provide some information, like their race and where they live. With the millions of data points the IAT provided, Eric painted a map of bias across the United States. Some places seem to have lots of bias, others very little. Now he had two databases. He cross-reference them to see if there was any connection between communities with disproportionate numbers of police shootings of minorities and community showing high levels of implicit bias.
一个强烈的相关性浮现了。因此我们发现，在人们具有更多种族偏见的社区中，非裔美国人被警察杀害的比例高于他们在人口中所占的比例。让我重复一遍，因为这很重要。在社区隐式偏见高于平均水平的地方，警察对少数族裔的枪击事件也高于平均水平。埃里克的分析有效地指出了警察枪击事件可能发生的地点。
A powerful correlation emerged. So we find that in communities in which people have more racial biases, African Americans are being killed more by police than their presence in the population would warrant. Let me repeat this because it's important. In places where implicit bias in a community is higher than average, police shootings of minorities are also higher than average. Erics analysis effectively pinpoints
但这就是这项发现令人疯狂的地方。大多数参加IAT的人都不是警察。所以我们并没有对警察本身进行测量，却预测了警察的行为。接下来，我们将探讨一项测试如何能够预测人们的行为，即使这些人根本没有参加过该测试。
where police shootings are likely to happen. But here's what makes the finding crazy. Most people who take the IAT are not police officers. So we're predicting police behavior by not measuring police at all themselves. Coming up, we explore how a test can predict how people will behave even when they are not the people who have taken the test.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹坦。在今天的节目中，我们正在讨论隐式偏见，即我们内心中塑造我们与世界互动方式的无意识态度。早些时候我们介绍了IAT，即隐式联想测验，这是一种用于测量个人隐式偏见的工具。心理学家埃里克·海曼通过比较隐式偏见水平高的地区与少数族裔警察枪击事件高于平均水平的地区，找到了一种预测警察行为的方法。既然警察通常不参加IAT，IAT怎么能预测他们的行为呢？
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. On today's show, we're discussing implicit bias, the unconscious attitudes we have in our minds that shape the ways we interact with the world. Earlier we introduced the IAT, the implicit association test, a tool used to measure a person's implicit biases. Psychologists Eric Heman found a way to predict police behavior by comparing places that have high levels of implicit bias with places where police shootings of minorities are higher than average. Since police typically don't take the IAT, how could the IAT be predicting their behavior?
埃里克认为，这项测试已经触及了整个社区的集体心智。比方说，有一个传统上与威胁或危险联系在一起的社区，而生活在这个社区的人们对非裔美国人和威胁，或者非裔美国人和危险有着这些联想。而这些人可以是这个社区里的任何人。
Eric thinks a test has tapped into the mind of the community as a whole. Say there's a neighborhood that's traditionally associated with threat or danger, and the people who live in that neighborhood have these associations between African Americans and threat or African Americans in danger. And these would be anybody in this community.
这可能是我的母亲或住在街那头的人，不一定非得是警察本身。但这种观点认为，这种态度在整个地区普遍存在，当警员在该地区执勤时，他们自己也可能拥有这种态度，这可能会影响他们在这些电光石火、极具挑战性的生死抉择中的行为。
This could be my mother or the person who lives down the street, not necessarily the police officers themselves. But there's this idea that this attitude is pervasive across the entire area, and that when officers are operating in that area, they themselves might share that same attitude, that might influence their behaviors in these split-second challenging life and death decisions.
隐式偏见就像悬浮在社区上空的雾霾。它成了人们呼吸的空气。或者正如哈佛大学心理学教授马扎林·巴纳吉所说的那样，文化的指纹正显现在生活在该社区的人们的头脑中。对于“个人心智塑造社区，而社区塑造个人心智中发生的事情”这一观点，有很多例子。
Implicit bias is like the smog that hangs over a community. It becomes the air that people breathe. Or as Harvard Psychology professor Maserine Banaji might say, the thumbprint of the culture is showing up in the minds of the people living in that community. There are many examples for this idea that individual minds shape the community
塞特·斯蒂芬斯-戴维塔维茨是一位曾供职于谷歌的数据科学家。我们以前在《隐藏的大脑》中介绍过他。在他的书《人人说谎》中，塞特解释了来自谷歌搜索的大数据如何能以极高的准确性预测社区的自杀率或发生仇恨犯罪的可能性等事情。我们已经证明，你可以根据人们的搜索预测针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪。
and the community shapes what happens in individual minds. Set Stevens-Devitawitz is a data scientist who used to work at Google. We featured him on Hidden Brain before. In his book, Everybody Lies, Seth explains how big data from Google searches can predict with great accuracy things like the suicide rate in a community or the chances that a hate crime will take place. We've shown that you can predict hate crimes against Muslims based on searches people make.
人们会进行非常、非常、非常令人不安的搜索，例如“杀死穆斯林”或“我恨穆斯林”。而这些搜索可以预测在给定的一周内会有多少针对穆斯林的仇恨犯罪。但我认为正确的方法不是针对任何特定的个人，去敲击任何特定个人的家门去针对任何一个进行这些搜索的特定个人。
People make very, very, very disturbing searches, searches such as Kill Muslims or I Hate Muslims. And these searches can predict on a given week how many hate crimes there will be against Muslims. But I think the right approach to this is not to target any particular individual to show up at the door target any particular individual to show up at the door of any particular individual who make these searches.
但如果在某个特定星期里有大量此类搜索，明智的做法是让警察部门在清真寺周围加强安保，因为这些袭击的威胁更大。换句话说，谷歌搜索数据正在做的事情实际上是在测量整个社区的温度。这才是你真正想表达的。你捕捉到的是空气中、社区里那些可能不会在个人身上显现，但在总体上很可能会显现的东西。是的，而且我认为你真的不知道任何特定个人进行搜索的原因，对吧？
But if there are many, many searches in a given week, it will be wise for police departments to put extra security around mosques because there is greater threat of these attacks. In other words, what the Google search data is doing is effectively taking the temperature of an entire community. That's what you're really saying. That you're picking up on things that are in the ether, if you will, in the community that might not show up in the individual, but are likely to show up in the aggregate. Yeah, and I think you don't really know the reason that any particular person makes a
一个人搜索“杀死穆斯林”可能是因为他们在做研究，或者他们只是对某事好奇，或者他们犯了个错误打错了字。个人进行这些搜索的原因有很多。但如果进行此类搜索的人数翻倍，好吧，如果我是美国穆斯林，我会希望清真寺周围有一些额外的安保，对吧？询问隐式偏见是否会影响每个人的行为，有点像去调查每一个在谷歌上输入攻击性搜索词的人。这种建议会影响每个人的行为，就像调查每一个在谷歌上输入攻击性搜索词的人一样。
search, right? Someone could be searching Kilm, as well as because they're doing research, or they're just curious about something, or they made made a mistake and they're typing. There are a lot of reasons that an individual can make these searches. But if twice as many people are making these searches, well, if I were a Muslim American, I'd want some extra security around my mosque, right? Asking whether implicit bias affects the behavior of every individual is a little like investigating everyone who types an offensive search term into Google. This advice affects the behavior of every individual, is a little like investigating everyone
很多时候，你什么也查不到。然而，当你从总体上看待搜索词时，它可以非常精确地告诉你哪些地区的仇恨犯罪会最多。就她而言，马扎林·巴纳吉认为埃里克的工作是她关于个人的心理学数据与关于我们社区行为的社会学见解之间的关键纽带。我们在这里发现的是，个人心智植根于社会之中，心智与社会之间的联系极其重要，绝不能被遗忘，
who types an offensive search term into Google. A lot of the time, you're going to find nothing. And yet, when you look at search terms and aggregate, it can tell you with great precision which areas will see the most hate crimes. For her part, Maasarine Banaji believes that Eric's work is a key link between her psychological data on individuals and sociological insights on how our community behaves. What we're discovering here is that the individual mind sits in society and the connection between mind and society is an extremely important one that should not be forgotten
并且与其他任何一群人相比，社会心理学家更有责任不忘他们学科的初心，兼顾这两方面，既要关注个人心智，又要讨论该心智如何既受到其周围更大的社会群体的影响，又反过来影响这个群体。这就是为什么马扎林说，当一个问题蔓延到整个社区时，
and that more than any other group of people, social psychologists, owe it to the beginnings of their discipline, to do both, and to do it even handedly, to be focused on the individual mind, and to be talking about how that mind is both influenced by and is influencing the larger social group around her. This is why Maasareen says, when a problem has spread throughout a community,
当它成为文化的一部分时，你不能仅仅通过关注个人来解决它。过去我们遇到的困难之一是，我们只看到个人并责怪个人。我们曾说，如果我们能从这支警队中清除这10名坏警察，我们就没事了。但作为社会科学家，我们知道，而且我坚信，那绝不是改变任何事情的方法。这种关于偏见的新思维方式在2016年总统大选中显现出来。民主党人希拉里·克林顿表示，隐式偏见可能在警察枪击事件中发挥了作用。我认为隐式偏见对每个人来说都是一个问题，不仅仅是警察。
when it has become part of the culture, you can't fix it by simply focusing on individuals. One of the difficulties we've had in the past is that we have looked at individual people and blamed individual people. We've said, if we can remove these 10 bad police officers from this force, we'll be fine. And we know, as social scientists, and I believe firmly that that is no way to change anything. This new way of thinking about bias showed up in the 2016 presidential election. Democrat Hillary Clinton said, implicit bias probably played a role in police shootings. I think implicit bias is a problem for everyone, not just police.
我认为不幸的是，我们伟大国家中的许多人对彼此妄下结论。共和党人迈克·彭斯（现任副总统）对这种说法感到恼火。他说希拉里·克林顿是在称警察为种族主义者。当一名非裔美国警察参与了一起涉及非裔美国人的警察执勤枪击事件时，希拉里·克林顿为什么会指责那名非裔美国警察谋杀？我想我简直不敢相信你在捍卫一种“不存在偏见”的立场。
I think unfortunately too many of us in our great country jumped to conclusions about each other. Republican Mike Pence, now Vice President, bristled the idea. He said that Hillary Clinton was calling cops racist. When an African-American police officer is involved in a police action shooting involving an African-American, why would Hillary Clinton accuse that African-American police officer of the murder? I guess I can't believe you are defending a position that there is no bias.
但正如马扎林所说，把带有隐式偏见的人等同于怀有我们通常所说“某人是种族主义者”时想到的那种种族敌意，是不太准确的。小孩子也会表现出隐式偏见。非裔美国人自己也会对其他非裔美国人表现出隐式偏见。这项测试捕捉到的不是少数愤怒的异见者的恶毒思想。它捕捉到的是每个人心智上的文化指纹。那么，我们能做什么呢？马扎林对那些提供承诺快速解决问题的培训课程的人持怀疑态度。
But as Maserine says, it's not quite right to think of people with implicit bias as harboring the kind of racial animosity we typically think of when we say someone is a racist. Small kids show implicit bias. African Americans themselves show implicit bias against other African Americans. The test isn't picking up the nasty thoughts of a few angry outliers. It's picking up the thumbprint of the culture on each of our minds. So, what can we do? Maasurina is skeptical of those who offer training courses that promise quick fix solutions.
全国各地有许多人声称他们提供这种被称为隐式偏见培训的服务。他们所做的是向大批人群解释可能发生了什么，是什么阻碍了他们实现自己的目标并成为他们自认为的好人。而我的担忧是，当我老去的时候，我会回首这段时光并心想，我为什么不对此做点什么呢，因为我不相信这种培训会有任何用处？在马扎林看来，你无法轻易抹去隐式偏见，因为你无法抹去文化的影响，
There are many people across the country who say that they offer such a thing, called implicit bias, training. And what they do is explain to large groups of people what might be going on that's keeping them from reaching their own goals and being the good people that they think they are. And my concern is that when I'm an old woman, that I will look back at this time and think, why didn't I do something about this because I don't believe this training is going to do anything? In Maasareen's view, you can't easily erase implicit bias because you can't erase the effect of the culture
当人们日复一日地生活在同一种文化中时。但她和其他人认为，也许有办法防止此类偏见影响我们的行为。也许有办法防止此类偏见影响我们的行为。让我们回到心理学家约书亚·科雷尔。记住，他就是那个创建了动态射击电子游戏的人，该游戏发现测试对象比白人更有可能向黑色目标开枪。约书亚的许多早期测试对象都是学生。最终，他决定看看
when people are living day in and day out in that same culture. But she and others argue that they might be ways to prevent such biases from influencing our behavior. might be ways to prevent such biases from influencing our behavior. Let's return to psychologist Joshua Correll. Remember, he's the one who created the active shooter video game that found that test takers were more likely to shoot black targets rather than white ones. Many of Joshua's initial test takers were students. Eventually, he decided to see
如果警察参加这个测试会发生什么。于是他找到了丹佛警方。我们带了一堆笔记本电脑和按键盒，一堆用来做这项研究的电子设备，然后我们把它安装在他们的点名室里。那简直是一团糟，但真的、真的非常有趣。有些警察根本不想理我们。但有大量的人自愿参加，他们还想在事后跟我们聊聊。起初，警官们的表现和其他所有人完全一样。他们的隐式偏见水平与参加测试的普通人差不多，无论是在反应时间还是在犯错数量上。
what would happen if police officers took the test. So he went to the Denver police. We brought down a bunch of laptops and button boxes, a bunch of electronic equipment that we were using to do this study, and we would set it up in their roll call room. And it was just complete chaos and really, really fun. And some of the police really wanted nothing to do with us. But a huge number of them volunteered and they wanted to talk with us afterwards. At first, the police officers performed exactly the same as everyone else. Their levels of implicit bias were about the same as the late people who have taken the test, both in response times and in the number of mistakes they made.
但当涉及到对目标的实际射击时，警察的表现却大不相同。警官们在实际开枪的对象上并没有表现出偏见。那些早期的测试对象——大学生和其他普通人——在反应时间、错误以及向谁开枪方面都表现出了他们的偏见。但警察没有。但是，当这些刻板印象可能会影响大学生以及你我的行为时，警察却不知何故能够施加控制。
But when it came to the actual shooting of targets, the police were very different. The police officers did not show a bias in who they actually shot. Those earlier test-takers, college students and other laypeople, displayed their bias on response times, mistakes, and who they shot. But not the police. But where are those stereotypes made influence the behavior of the college students and of you and me, the police officers are somehow able to exert control.
因此，尽管关于威胁的刻板印象可能会浮现，但警官能够克服这种刻板印象，根据现场实际呈现的信息做出反应，而不是根据警官自己通过其刻板印象带来的信息做出反应。约书亚想知道，是否存在某些因素可以阻止警官对他们的偏见施加这种认知控制。他发现，除其他因素外，睡眠会产生影响。睡眠不足的人在开枪决策中更有可能表现出种族偏见。再说一次，这与这种观点完全一致，即他们可能
So even though the stereotype, say of threat, may come to mind, the officer can overcome that stereotype and respond based on the information that's actually present in the scene rather than information that the officer is bringing to it through his or her stereotypes. Joshua wondered whether there were certain factors that might keep police officers from exerting this kind of cognitive control over their biases. He found, among other things, that sleep made a difference. Those who were getting less sleep were more likely to show racial bias in their decisions to shoot. And again, that's just consistent with this idea that they are, they might
能够施加控制，利用认知资源来避免在决策中表现出刻板偏见，但当这些资源受损时，他们就做不到了。它们可能会以各种方式受损。睡眠只是我们可能损害它的一种方式。这再次证明，你无法训练人们没有无意识偏见，但正如约书亚所建议的那样，你可以采取措施降低人们受其偏见影响的可能性。需要明确的是，约书亚的实验是实验室实验。我们知道在现实生活中，警察确实会错误地开枪。
be able to exert control, to use cognitive resources to avoid showing stereotypic bias in their decisions, but when those resources are compromised, they can't do it. They could be compromised in a variety of ways. Sleep is just one way they can't do it. They could be compromised in a variety of ways. Sleep is just one way that we could compromise it. This, once again, is evidence that you can't train people not to have unconscious bias, but as Joshua suggests, you can do things to make it less likely that people will be affected by their bias. To be clear, Joshua's experiments are laboratory experiments. We know that in real life, police officers do shoot people in error.
现在这可能是因为在现实世界的遭遇中，会发生一些事情，使你很难真正思考你在做什么。所以在街上，当有人对你拔枪时，这很可怕，对吧？就像警察卷入这些枪战时会报告一些疯狂的、疯狂的心理扭曲，因为他们真的吓坏了。如果他们认为某人构成了生死威胁，他们可能会惊慌失措，并且很难调用这些认知资源。在最近几起备受瞩目的案件中，就像特伦斯·克劳彻和贝蒂·谢尔比的案子一样，警察枪杀没有武装的人。当然，警察并不总是知道某人是否携带武器。
Now this could be because in real life encounter, stuff happens that makes it very difficult for you to actually think about what you're doing. So on the street, when somebody pulls a gun on you, It's scary, right? Like, cops when they're involved in these firefights report some crazy, crazy psychological distortions because they're legitimately freaked out. If they think somebody poses a life and death threat, they may panic, and it may be hard to bring those cognitive resources online. In several recent high profile cases, as in the case of Terence Cratcher and Betty Shelby, police officers shoot people who are not armed. Of course, officers do not always know whether someone is armed.
这可能是因为在现实生活的遭遇中，会发生很多事情，让你很难去思考自己正在做什么。所以在街头，当有人用枪指着你时，这很可怕，对吧？比如，警察在卷入这些枪战时，会报告一些疯狂的、疯狂的心理扭曲，因为他们确实被吓坏了。如果他们认为某人构成了生死威胁，他们可能会惊慌失措，并且可能很难调动这些认知资源。在几个最近备受瞩目的案件中，正如特伦斯·克拉切尔（Terence Cratcher）和贝蒂·谢尔比（Betty Shelby）的案件一样，警官向没有武装的人开枪。当然，警官并不总是知道某人是否携带武器。
It's only in hindsight that we know the officer was or wasn't in real danger. Joshua's larger point is that police encounters can be inherently stressful. The uncertainty embedded in a confrontation can make it very difficult to think objectively. Let's put it another way. If you're running a police department and want to reduce errors and shootings, it may not be useful to lecture cops on how they shouldn't be racist. It may be more useful to build procedures that give cops an extra half second when they're making decisions under pressure. With practice and a bit of time to exercise conscious control, people can reduce the risk of falling prey to their implicit biases.
直到事后，我们才知道警官当时是否真的处于危险之中。约书亚更深层的观点是，警察执勤往往具有天然的压力。对峙中蕴含的不确定性，会使人很难进行客观思考。换句话说，如果你在管理一个警察局，想要减少失误和开枪事件，向警察说教“你们不应该有种族偏见”可能并没有太大用处。更有用的做法是建立一些程序，让警察在压力下做决定时能多出半秒钟的时间。通过练习和一点点进行意识控制的时间，人们可以降低落入内隐偏见陷阱的风险。
There is the potential to control it, right? The performance of the regular police officers or even people that we train in our lab suggests that people don't have to succumb to those stereotypic influences. They can exert control in certain circumstances. Maserine Banaji has a similar solution. She thinks we need more of what she calls in the moment reminders. For example, it's been found that some doctors prescribe painkillers to white patients far more often than they do to black patients who are reporting exactly
我们是有可能控制它的，对吧？普通警官甚至是我们在实验室里训练的人的表现都表明，人们并不一定要屈服于那些刻板印象的影响。他们在某些情况下是可以施加控制的。马扎林·班aji（Mahzarin Banaji）也有类似的解决方案。她认为我们需要更多她所谓的“即时提醒”。例如，人们发现，有些医生给白人患者开止痛药的频率，远远高于那些报告了完全相同疼痛水平的黑人患者。
the same levels of pain. The only difference is the patient's skin color. This suggests that bias is at work. Maserine says if the bias is implicit, meaning physicians are acting biased without intending to be biased, a timely reminder can help doctors exercise conscious control over their unconscious associations. You type in a painkiller that you want to prescribe to a patient
唯一的区别是患者的皮肤颜色。这表明偏见正在起作用。马扎林表示，如果这种偏见是内隐的，意味着医生在无意中表现出了偏见，那么及时的提醒可以帮助医生对他们的无意识联想进行有意识的控制。当患者坐在你旁边时，你在电子系统中输入你想给患者开的止痛药。
into your electronic system while the patient is sitting next to you. And it seems to me quite simple that when you type in the name of any painkiller, let's say, Codine, that a little graph pops up in front of you that says, please note, in our hospital system, we have noticed that this is the average amount of painkiller we give to white men. This is the average amount we give to black men for the same reported level of pain. In other words, giving doctors an opportunity to stop for a second to make a decision consciously and deliberately. This can reduce the effect of implicit bias.
在我看来，这其实很简单：当你输入任何止痛药的名字，比如可待因时，你的眼前就会弹出一个小图表，上面写着：“请注意，在我们的医院系统中，我们注意到这是我们给白人男性的平均止痛药剂量，这是我们针对相同报告疼痛水平给黑人男性的平均剂量。”换句话说，就是给医生一个停顿一秒钟、有意识且慎重做决定的机会。这可以减少内隐偏见的影响。
Psychology has spent many years understanding the behavior of individuals, but tools such as the IAT give us a way to understand communities as a whole. Maybe even countries as a whole. We did a study some years ago, Brian Nosek led this particular project in which we looked at gender stereotypes across many countries in the world. How strongly do we associate female with science and male with science? And then we looked at the performance of girls and boys roughly around eighth grade on some kind of a standardized test. And what we discovered is that the stronger the gender bias in a country, that is to say the stronger the association of male with science in a country,
心理学花了很多年时间来了解个体的行为，但诸如IAT（内隐联想测验）之类的工具为我们提供了一种了解整个社区的方法。甚至可能是整个国家。几年前我们做过一项研究，布赖恩·诺塞克（Brian Nosek）领导了这个特定的项目，我们研究了世界上许多国家的性别刻板印象。我们把女性和科学联系在一起、以及把男性和科学联系在一起的程度有多强？然后我们观察了全球大约八年级左右的女孩和男孩在某种标准化测试中的表现。我们发现的是，一个国家的性别偏见越强，也就是说，一个国家将男性与科学联系得越紧密，
the less well girls in that country did on that mathematics test. It's very similar to the Haman kind of result because we didn't measure the gender bias in the girls and the boys who took the test. We were measuring something at the level of a country in that case. And yet, it did predict something systematic about the difference in performance between boys and girls.
这个国家的女孩在数学测试中的表现就越差。这与哈曼（Heineken/Haman）的那类结果非常相似，因为我们没有去测量参加测试的女孩和男孩身上的性别偏见。在那种情况下，我们衡量的是国家层面的东西。然而，它确实对男孩和女孩表现差异的系统性情况做出了一些预测。
When we look at an event like a police shooting, we invariably seek to understand it at the level of individuals. If something bad happens, we think it has to be because someone had bad intentions. Implicit bias certainly does act on individuals, but it's possible that its strongest effects are at the level of a community as a whole. This might be why some police shootings of African American men are carried out by African American police officers and why some physicians who are not prescribing pain medications to people of color might themselves be people of color. Individuals can do their part to limit the effects of bias on their behavior.
当我们审视像警察枪击案这样的事件时，我们总是倾向于从个人层面去理解它。如果发生了不好的事情，我们就会认为这一定是因为某人有不良动机。内隐偏见确实会对个人产生作用，但它最强烈的效应可能存在于整个社区的层面。这或许可以解释为什么有些针对非裔美国男性的警察枪击案是由非裔美国警察执行的，以及为什么有些不给有色人种开止痛药的医生本身可能就是有色人种。个人可以尽自己的一份力量来限制偏见对其行为的影响。
But if you want to fix the bias itself, well, that takes the whole village. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We'll be back in a moment. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you follow football, for our listeners in other countries we're talking about American football, this will sound familiar. At several points in a game, the action comes to a stop because a ruling that a referee has made on the field has to be reviewed. When this happens, everyone turns to the television replay, an expert's both on and off the field decide whether the referee made the right call. Each time a referee's ruling gets reversed, it's a small blemish on his reputation. If your calls get overturned a lot, people will start to say that
但如果你想根除偏见本身，那就需要全村人的努力了。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹坦（Shankar Vedantam）。我们一会儿回来。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。如果你关注橄榄球——对于我们其他国家的听众，我们这里指的是美式橄榄球——这听起来会很熟悉。在比赛的几个时间点，比赛会暂停，因为裁判在场上做出的判决必须进行回放复核。每当这种情况发生时，所有人都会转向电视回放，场内外的专家们会决定裁判是否做出了正确的判决。裁判的判决每被推翻一次，就是对他的声誉的一个小污点。如果你的判决经常被推翻，人们就会开始说
you're a bad referee. What happens in football is an analogy for something much more important. At Harvard's Kennedy School, political scientist Maya San has examined how rulings in the federal courts get upheld or overturned. And the traditional viewpoint in the legal academy is that for a judge to be reversed, it's actually quite costly. As in sports, it can be costly to that judge's reputation, it can sort of be a mark that they perhaps reached an incorrect decision or a decision that was too extreme or unpalatable to the higher court.
你是个糟糕的裁判。橄榄球中发生的事情，其实是一个更重要问题的类比。在哈佛大学肯尼迪学院，政治学家玛雅·森（Maya Sen）研究了联邦法院的判决是如何被维持或推翻的。法学界的传统观点认为，法官的判决被推翻，其实代价相当高昂。正如在体育运动中一样，这可能会损害法官的声誉，这可能某种程度上标志着他们可能做出了不正确的决定，或者做出了对上级法院来说过于极端或令人难以接受的决定。
In other words, costly to an individual judge, but also costly to the system as a whole. Reversal sends the case back, right? So it's sent back to a lower court usually and that lower court doesn't have a reduced work flows or result. It just has to accommodate another case being handed back down to it. And so it's costly not just in terms of reputational costs, but it's actually also costly because it adds more work onto a judge's plate. We're talking this hour about implicit biases subtle nudges that might cause us to evaluate
换句话说，这不仅对个别法官代价高昂，对整个系统来说也是代价高昂的。判决被推翻会将案件发回重审，对吧？所以它通常会被发回给下级法院，而下级法院的工作量并没有因此减少。它只是必须处理另一个被发回给它的案件。因此，它不仅在声誉成本方面代价高昂，而且实际上由于给法官的工作增加了更多负担，也是代价高昂的。我们这一小时在谈论内隐偏见——那些可能导致我们对某些人的评价与对其他人不同的微妙推动力。
some people differently than others. There has been some really interesting work showing that, for example, employers who look at resumes that are sent essentially on an identical basis with the names at the top of the resumes either being white names or traditionally African-American names have resulted in massive differences, for example, in callback rates and things like that. Maya wanted to know if such biases might also shape which judicial rulings get overturned or more specifically which judges get overturned. Even more simply, she asked, do black judges get reversed more often than white ones? Before we get to the research, a quick bit of history. There are hundreds of judges in the U.S. federal court system,
有一些非常有趣的研究表明，例如，雇主在查看简历时，简历的内容基本完全相同，唯一的区别是简历顶部的名字是白人名字还是传统的非裔美国人名字，这导致了例如回电率等方面的巨大差异。玛雅想知道，这种偏见是否也会决定哪些司法判决被推翻，或者更具体地说，哪些法官更容易被推翻。更简单地说，她提出了一个问题：黑人法官被推翻的频率是否比白人法官更高？在我们进入这项研究之前，先回顾一小段历史。美国联邦法院系统中有数百名法官，
and up until the 1960s, all of them were white. Through the 1960s and into the 1970s, there was a big push to diversify the courts in the United States. Presidents like Jimmy Carter began appointing black judges to the courts. The thing is, these judges were usually the most junior members of the system. Our judicial system is very hierarchical. So there are certain courts at the bottom,
直到20世纪60年代，他们全部都是白人。在20世纪60年代到70年代期间，美国掀起了一股推动法院多元化的热潮。像吉米·卡特这样的总统开始任命黑人法官进入法院。问题是，这些法官通常是系统中资历最浅的成员。我们的司法系统等级森半森严。所以底层有一些特定的法院，
and then there is the Supreme Court at the top. And along the way, the way that cases get up to these higher courts is by being appealed. So if someone goes to a federal court and doesn't like the way a judge has ruled, she can challenge that judge's decision by filing an appeal. So if a case is appealed to a higher court, then that higher court has the opportunity to uphold the lower courts ruling or reverse it.
最高处则是最高法院。在这个过程中，案件到达这些上诉法院的方式是通过上诉。因此，如果有人去联邦法院，且不喜欢某个法官的判决，她可以通过提起上诉来挑战该法官的决定。因此，如果一个案件被上诉到上级法院，那么上级法院就有机会维持下级法院的判决或将其推翻。
As we said before, judges whose rulings get overturned a lot are at risk for being seen as less competent. What was the hypothesis, so what did you think about, as you were sort of saying, while reversals might tell me something interesting, what was the hypothesis that you wanted to explore? So in the case of reversal, my working hypothesis was whether black judges would be reversed more on appeal than white judges. What was the, you looked at a specific group of judges, so tell me a little bit about the data set you looked at and why you looked at that data set?
正如我们之前所说，判决经常被推翻的法官面临着被认为能力不足的风险。那么你的假设是什么？你在思考时是怎么想的？正如你刚才所说，虽然判决被推翻可能会告诉我一些有趣的事情，但你想要探索的假设是什么？所以在判决被推翻的案件中，我的工作假设是：黑人法官在上诉中被推翻的概率是否会比白人法官更高？那么你研究的是一个特定的法官群体，所以请告诉我一些关于你所研究的数据集以及你为什么选择这个数据集的信息？
I did, so for this study I chose the federal courts. And I chose to look at federal judges in part because they are sort of the more prestigious of the courts in the United States. We tend to have the best data. We tend to have the most information about them, which from my perspective is a quantitative data scientist is appealing. Maya looked at judges of all races appointed between 1960 and 2012. 10% or so. We're African-American.
我确实研究了。所以在这项研究中，我选择了联邦法院。我选择研究联邦法院，部分原因是因为它们在美国的法院中算是比较声望较高的。我们往往能拥有最好的数据。我们往往拥有关于它们的最多的信息，从我这个定量数据科学家的角度来看，这很有吸引力。玛雅研究了在1960年至2012年期间被任命的所有种族的法官。大约10%
And analyzed how often their cases were appealed and how often their rulings were overturned. What did you find? So essentially what we find, what I find, and this is very consistent across different kinds of ways of slicing and dicing the data, which is that black judges have a very, very consistently, have a consistently higher reversal rate. They are much more likely to be reversed once a case that they've written has been appealed to a higher court. And that's the case regardless of whether we control for or take into account
是非裔美国人。并分析了他们的案件被上诉的频率以及判决被推翻的频率。你发现了什么？所以基本上我们发现的，我发现的，这在切分和分析数据的各种不同方法中都是非常一致的，那就是黑人法官拥有非常、非常一致的、更高的判决被推翻率。一旦他们撰写的判决案子上诉到上级法院，他们就更有可能被推翻。而且无论我们是否控制或考虑了以下因素，情况都是如此：
differences in the court in which they sit, the kinds of cases that they hear, their age, their gender, their professional experience, their qualifications ratings from the American Bar Association. It's actually a very, very sticky finding, so essentially black judges are more likely to be reversed by higher courts. At the University of Chicago Law School, Dean Tom Miles reviewed Maya study. Well, the conclusions of the paper are surprising because, of course, judges are, and particularly appellate judges, are very much attuned to look for racial disparities elsewhere in the
他们所在的法院的差异、他们审理的案件类型、他们的年龄、性别、职业经历、美国律师协会的资格评级。这实际上是一个非常、非常稳健的发现，所以基本上黑人法官更容易被上级法院推翻。在芝加哥大学法学院，汤姆·迈尔斯（Tom Miles）院长审阅了玛雅的研究。嗯，这篇论文的结论令人惊讶，因为当然，法官，特别是上诉法院法官，非常敏锐地去寻找法律系统其他地方的
legal system. This is a disturbing finding. Now, what happens to black judges could be the result of racial bias. But before we reach that troubling conclusion, there is another theory we need to consider. This theory is much more innocuous. To explain what I mean, let's take a short detour. If you live through the 1990s in the United States, you might be able to sing a couple of lines from this theme song. The fresh prince of Belaire isn't set in a courtroom and doesn't really discuss the judicial system except one of the main characters, Uncle Phil, is a judge.
种族差异。这是一个令人不安的发现。现在，黑人法官身上发生的事情可能是种族偏见的结果。但在我们得出这个令人不安的结论之前，我们需要考虑另一种理论。这个理论要无害得多。为了解释我的意思，让我们做一个简短的绕道。如果你在美国度过了20世纪90年代，你或许能哼出这首主题曲的几句歌词。《新鲜王子妙事多》（The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air）并不是以法庭为背景的，也没有真正讨论司法系统，除了其中一个主要角色菲尔叔叔（Uncle Phil）是一名法官。
He's a straight-laced character who often wears a suit, and he cringes at the way his nephew will, dresses and speaks. Oh, yo, the plane rower's open all of the first minute. Now that the plane was dope. Excuse me? No, stupid dope. Oh, no, that doesn't mean what you, um, how would he, the flight was really neat here. In the show's pilot episode, Will and Uncle Phil
他是一个循规蹈矩的角色，经常穿着西装，他对他的侄子威尔的穿着和说话方式感到局促不安。哦，哟，飞机的舱门在第一分钟就打开了。现在这架飞机太酷了。对不起？不，是酷毙了。哦，不，那可不是你……呃，他是怎么说的，这里的航班真的很棒。在该剧的试播集中，威尔和菲尔叔叔
get into an argument. Will accuses his uncle of forgetting his roots. Let me tell you something, son. I grew up on the streets just like you. I encountered bigotry. You could not imagine. Now, you have a nice poster of Malcolm X on your wall. I heard the brother speak.
发生了争执。威尔指责他的叔叔忘本。让我告诉你一件事，孩子。我和你一样在街头长大。我遭遇过你无法想象的偏执。现在，你的墙上贴着一张马尔科姆·X（Malcolm X）的好海报。我听过这位兄弟的演讲，
I read every word he wrote, believe me, I know where I come from. Uncle Phyllis, something of a prototype for the black judges appointed to the federal judiciary in the 1960s. As Maya says, black judges who were appointed early or so in the 1960s, 1970s, primarily by Jimmy Carter, were more likely to come from the trenches of the civil rights movement.
我读过他写的每一个字，相信我，我知道我来自哪里。菲尔叔叔可以说是20世纪60年代被任命到联邦司法系统的黑人法官的一个原型。正如玛雅所说，早期被任命的黑人法官，也就是在20世纪60年代、70年代，主要由吉米·卡特任命的那些人，更有可能来自民事权利运动的前线。
As a result, she says, studies have found that black judges do tend to vote differently on certain kinds of cases. Black judges tend to vote in a more progressive or liberal direction on cases having to do with affirmative action and civil rights. My eye acknowledges that this could be a potential explanation for her finding that black judges are more likely to be reversed than white ones. They aren't being reversed because they're black, they're being reversed because they're ideologically liberal.
因此，她说，研究发现黑人法官在某些类型的案件上的投票倾向确实不同。在涉及平权行动和民权问题的案件中，黑人法官倾向于以更加进步或自由主义的方向投票。玛雅承认，这可能是对她发现的“黑人法官比白人法官更容易被推翻”这一结果的一种潜在解释。他们被推翻不是因为他们是黑人，而是因为他们在意识形态上是自由派。
So therefore, when their cases are being appealed to higher courts, higher courts might have fewer African Americans, perhaps fewer liberals, and because of that, cases written by black judges who perhaps are more liberal are therefore more likely to be overturned. So in other words, racial bias might have absolutely nothing to do with Maya's finding, right? At the University of Chicago Law School, Tom Miles says the innocuous explanation is unlikely to be true. Maya's research, he says, clearly shows that ideological differences cannot explain the outcome she finds. That's because Maya controls for the effects of ideology. By looking at whether black democratic judges are more likely to be overturned than white democratic judges.
因此，当他们的案件被上诉到上级法院时，上级法院可能拥有较少的非裔美国人，或许较少的自由派，正因为如此，由可能更倾向于自由主义的黑人法官所撰写的案件因此更有可能被推翻。换句话说，种族偏见可能与玛雅的发现完全没有关系，对吧？在芝加哥大学法学院，汤姆·迈尔斯表示，这种无害的解释不太可能是真的。他说，玛雅的研究清楚地表明，意识形态上的差异无法解释她所发现的结果。这是因为玛雅控制了意识形态的影响。
And she finds even in that context the racial gap exists. Since judges are appointed by both Republican and Democratic presidents, Maya reran her study by looking only at judges appointed by Democrats. Presumably, all these judges have liberal sympathies. But even in this group, the analysis finds that black liberal judges get reversed more often than white liberal judges. Even when they're facing in a pellet review panel that consists of other democratic judges, and she finds even in that context the racial gap exists.
通过观察民主党籍的黑人法官是否比民主党籍的白人法官更容易被推翻。她发现，即使在这种情况下，种族差距依然存在。由于法官是由共和党和民主党总统共同任命的，玛雅重新运行了她的研究，只观察由民主党人任命的法官。据推测，所有这些法官都有自由派的同情倾向。但即使在这个群体中，分析也发现，自由派黑人法官比自由派白人法官被推翻的频率更高。甚至当他们面对由其他民主党法官组成的上诉复审小组时，她发现即使在这种情况下，种族差距依然存在。
And so, on the first inspection, it doesn't appear that ideology is the explanation for the result. Now this study doesn't allow us to test whether unconscious biases are producing this outcome. But Tom says the outcome is at least consistent with what we know about unconscious bias. It's certainly consistent with the existing literature
因此，初看起来，意识形态似乎并不是这一结果的解释。现在，这项研究不允许我们测试无意识偏见是否产生了这一结果。但汤姆表示，这一结果至少与我们对无意识偏见的了解是一致的。它当然与现有的文献相一致，即内隐偏见存在于社会的各个层面，
that implicit biases exist at all levels of society and thus it's not unthinkable to imagine that it might also exist among judges. But of course that would be a very controversial claim to say that judges in making their legal decisions in which they're relying on legal materials are influenced by their knowledge of the identity of the lower court judge. Maya notes that younger black judges don't have the same activist backgrounds as their predecessors. Black judges today are actually more likely to have attended Harvard Law School than
因此，想象它也可能存在于法官之中并非不可想象。但当然，这将是一个非常具争议的的主张，即法官在做出依赖法律材料的法律裁决时，会受到他们对下级法院法官身份认知的影响。玛雅指出，年轻的黑人法官并不像他们的前辈那样拥有相同的激进主义背景。如今的黑人法官实际上更有可能毕业于哈佛法学院，而不是
Howard Law School. And so they're more likely to have come from private practice, more likely to have attained prestigious clerkships, and they're actually starting to look professionally at least more like white judges. Does this mean that younger black judges are less likely to be reversed than their older counterparts? You might have a sense of where this is headed. The answer is no.
霍华德法学院。因此，他们更有可能来自私人执业律师事务所，更有可能获得声望很高的书记员职位，而且他们在职业外观上实际上开始看起来更像白人法官了。这是否意味着年轻的黑人法官比年长的同行更不容易被推翻？你可能对事情的走向有所预感。答案是：不会。
Maya says younger black judges are just as likely to have that case as reversed upon appeal. Is one of the implications of this is if you get reversed a lot, are you less likely than to advance through the courts? You know, that's a good question. That's certainly the public or the legal scholarly perception, which is that reversal might be a signal of an underlying problem.
玛雅说，年轻的黑人法官在案件上诉时被推翻的可能性和年长者一样高。这意味着什么？其中一个含义是，如果你经常被推翻，你通过法院晋升的可能性是不是就更小了？你知道，这是个好问题。这当然是公众或法律学界的看法，即判决被推翻可能是一个潜在问题的信号。
So if you have a judge with very, very high reversal rates, that could potentially be a judge who perhaps writes poor quality opinions, or whose legal reasoning is problematic, or who's more ideologically extreme, or is too large of a risk taker. As the country has gotten more diverse, we've sought to make the judiciary more diverse as well. Americans who show up in federal court today
所以，如果你有一个判决被推翻率非常、非常高的法官，那可能潜在地说明这位法官撰写的意见质量不高，或者其法律推理存在问题，或者在意识形态上更极端，或者是个风险承担倾向过大的人。随着国家变得更加多元化，我们也一直在努力使司法系统更加多元化。今天出现在联邦法庭上的美国人，
are more likely to see an African-American sitting at the bench compared to that counterparts half a century ago. Many people dig justifiable pride in this change. Where this paper kind of fits in is pushing back on that a little bit and sort of asking, well, it seems to be true that these judges are introducing this diverse viewpoint. But what does that actually mean if that diverse viewpoint is then eventually overruled
与半个世纪前的同行相比，更有可能看到非裔美国人坐在法官席上。许多人为这种变化感到理所当然的自豪。这篇论文的契合点有点在于对这一点进行一些回推，并提出这样的问题：嗯，这些法官确实引入了这种多元化的观点，这似乎是真的。但如果这种多元化观点最终被
by higher courts? In other words, it's one thing to appoint people of color, but for diversity to actually take root and flourish, the entire ecosystem has to embrace the newcomers and their ideas. If it doesn't, diversity ends up being mostly about optics. This episode was produced by Janishmet, Raina Cohen, Parts Shah and Maggie Penman. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Rainy Clark does our social media.
上级法院推翻，这究竟意味着什么？换句话说，任命有色人种是一回事，但要让多元化真正在基层扎根并蓬勃发展，整个生态系统必须拥抱新来者及其观点。如果没有做到这一点，多元化最终将仅仅流于表面。本期节目由贾尼斯·迈特（Janishmet）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕特·沙阿（Parts Shah）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）对其进行了剪辑。雷尼·克拉克（Rainy Clark）负责我们的社交媒体。
We had original music in this episode from Rampti and Arableui. For more hidden brain, please follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. And if you know a friend who would like to hear our show, please tell them about hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目的原创音乐来自兰普蒂（Rampti）和阿拉布鲁伊（Arableui）。想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的信息，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们。如果你认识一个想听我们节目的朋友，请把《隐藏的大脑》推荐给他们。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦，下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。